υυπάρχει επάγγελμα που δεν έχει διευθαρμένος κανένα κανένα επαγγελμα πολιτικό δημοσιογράφο δικαιγόρων αστυνομικών πυρασβεστών όλα
τα παγγέλματα τώρα το πως ωστό και ο τρόπος που διαρευνάς είναι αυτό που πεζηρόλοαυτή
τη στιμή βρίσκονται ποδιερεύνηση μ δεν ποινδύο της εκατόν από τους πεντέμιση έει γιάδες αστυνομικούς
γιαδιαυθορά πολύ χαμιλών προστοθεσίαμου για αστυνομία στο εξωτερικό να πω δια πράδειγμα η μητροπολιτική αστυνομία
του λονδίνου έχει τρία της εκατόν πό τα μέλι της υποέρευνα για διαυφορά έχουμε τρεις
υπηρεσίες να μας ελέγχουν έχουμε διακόσες πενήντα υποθέσεις τα τελευταία χρόνια πιθααρχηκές αναντιών αστυνομικών τέσσερεις
πιθαρχηκές μέσον όρω καθεμήνα ενώ τα αυτό χρόνα τέσσερε σ αστυνομική εκδιοκθηκαν τα τελευταία δέκα
χρόνια για πνι κίνι για διαυθορά από ποινικό δικαστυριών που αποδείχθηκε αυτό δείχνει ότι ιέκλησαν
οις συμπληγάδες δεν μπορείς πλέων να παίζεις με τη διαυθοράν και νομίζε ότι σε μόνος
σου κα θεωρώ ότι είμαστε μπροστά σε μια ναλλαγήει σε αυτόν το κεφάλιον αλλά επίτρεψεμου
να μη συχίζουμε θιο πράγματα για να διοργάνωσης αστυνομίας εν άλλων πράμα και διαθορά εμέρως
τις αναδιοργανωσης ναιμε αλλά σίουρα τισία ότι έχω θπιο αστυνομικούς τώρα στον σταθμό και έχει
καμια σχέσι μέ διαυθορα έσ αι να μην να μην προβάλλου μιλόγια σας μιλό και
για για μας εκτονέσω να μην πρόβαλλουμε τη διαυθοράν ως βιτριγνα για νακαλύφκουμε άλλα πράματα
σι για τα πατενα τηλαοη οικόνα της αστυνομίας σήμερα ναι θεωρίσε ότι είναι αστυνομία που
αρμόζει σε μιαν ευρωπαϊκή χώρα όλοι αυτοή υποστελέχωση όλα αυτά που βλέπουμε τα προβλήματα της
πρώτης γράμμεις οι ελείψεις είναι μας αρμόζει αυτή αστυνομία όχι δν μας αρμόζει για δύο
λόγους πρώτο υπιτητα του κύπριου αστυνομικό υπιότητα είναι τεράστια υπιότητα του κύπριο αστνομιού και προσαστηνομικς
έρχει τρομερές εκανόνηρε τρομερές